- All right y'all.
It's almost time to say goodbye.
But before we go I have
one more story of goodness
I hope you'll enjoy.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
So last week I received the
sweetest mother's day gift
from my friend Dule Hill.
Take a look.
- What's that?
- Well, I have to tell you.
- Okay.
- Well, I come bearing a gift.
- You're my favorite guest.
- Yes.
- Yeah. (Kelly laughing)
- Here's the thing.
My wife, Jazmyn Simon
wrote a children's book.
- Oh yeah.
- Called The Most Perfect You.
- [Kelly} Okay.
- And it's an ode to
motherhood and self love.
And it's a reminder to anyone who's ever
compared themself to anyone,
that they're perfect exactly
the way that they are.
- I hope the book in there for my kids.
- You see in honor of rad mom's week.
One rad mom, my wife, Jazmyn Simon.
Wanted to present to you, another rad mom.
This token of love to remind you
that you are and always will
be the most perfect you.
- I love this.
(crowd applauding)
No surprise, his wife
is an amazing writer.
I took the book home and my kids loved it.
We literally read every night.
And it's like exciting for them now.
It was like forced family fun at first.
But I wanted to bring her
on cuz we love the book.
So everybody say hi to actress and author,
Jazmyn Simon.
(crowd cheering)
- [Kelly] Hi.
Oh, you look stunning.
Oh my gosh.
Well I have to say first
you look beautiful.
Secondly, I love the message of the book.
- [Jazmyn] Thank you.
- It's so important for kids,
so tell me what inspired you to do it?
- Well, we have a 17 year
old daughter named Kennedy,
who's a senior in high school
and a three and newly three
year old son named Levi.
And when our daughter
Kennedy was three years old,
we were riding in the car.
And from the back seat she says to me,
"Mommy, I wanna be pretty."
"I need my skin to be white."
And I said, "oh my God."
And then, "Well Kennedy,
when you were in my belly
I actually had a conversation with God.
And I told him
that I wanted you to have
my favorite color of skin.
And that's why you're brown.
And actually every single thing about you
I got to pick myself.
You have my favorite eyes,
my favorite nose,
my favorite hair.
You are all of my favorite things."
And she thought about it.
And she said, "okay."
And she moved on from the conversation.
And in 2020, I looked out,
we were going through a global pandemic.
We had saw George Floyd
get murdered on TV.
And I thought, oh my God
what this world needs right now is love.
And I want our children to know
that they are perfect just
the way that they are.
And so I wrote a book
called Most Perfect You,
to remind children
and the people that read to their children
that they are absolutely perfect.
Not in comparison to somebody else,
but exactly the way that they are.
- I love it.
(audience applauding)
It's just powerful all around.
Thank you so much for sharing.
Thank you so much, Jazmyn,
for the book as well.
Cuz we read a lot at our house
so it's nice to have a new book.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
- [Jazmyn] Thank you.
- All right.
So Most Perfect You by Jazmyn Simon.
Illustrations by Tamisha
Anthony, which are beautiful.
It's now available wherever
you get your books.
Usually at this point in the show
we'd give our guest a
thousand dollars courtesy
of our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of Friction, the go-to erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson show.
But today, since you know,
she got money, she fine.
That money's going to
someone in the audience.
And so look under your chairs.
Somebody has it right now.
(drum roll)
Somebody has a thousand
dollars under their chair.
(drum roll)
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Okay.
Okay, okay.
First of all, I love that you're in jeans.
Like all these women in dresses,
trying to be like polite about it.
You can just like squat up under there
and you took your time.
What's your name?
Where are you from?
- My name is Kimina.
I'm from Argentina.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
Beautiful accent.
(audience applauding)
I just want to hear you talk more.
I went to this states like two months ago.
Oh my God.
Well here's a thousand dollars.
Have fun.
Yeah. So fun.
- Thank you.